hi everyone I'm Madison Mills a reporter
at quick-take with Bloomberg News I'm
joined here today by Miami mayor Francis
Suarez to talk about the rise in Kovan
19 cases across the state of Florida and
specifically in Miami for those of you
watching at home please comment with any
questions you have for the mayor and
we're gonna be looking at these comments
throughout our chat and I'll get to as
many of those questions as I can mr.
Mary I want to start off by just asking
how you're feeling you were one of the
first elected officials in the u.s. to
have coronavirus so how are you holding
up holding up well I mean obviously I
was important for 18 days and then you
know having to deal with major this
pandemic which is still ongoing and
fortunately seeing the uptick that we're
seeing now which is extremely alarming
and concerning and then of course
dealing with the protests that you know
all cities are dealing with in the
United States has really created a lot
of challenges for cities across the
country absolutely and in terms of your
symptoms are you feeling okay I know
you've got a lot on your plate but are
you are you well all things considered
yeah I know I've tested multiple times
I've done a lot of antibody tests and
Justin ever since it's just a negative
and eighty now not tested positive again
and you know antibody tests that I've
taken that indicate that I still have
had advice for the year for the coat fur
coat well that is great news we're gonna
get into all of the topics that you
mentioned I do want to start out by
talking about the rise in Coppa 19 cases
particularly in your in your backyard
what do you attribute this rise to you
know it's hard to say we opened on
whether the the last thing that opened
in the state of Florida so basically by
behind miami-dade Broward Palm Beach
counties which lagging behind the entire
state and I think for us we start to see
the data shift after we open up
restaurants which was in Phase two or
phase one B once we opened up
restaurants and we have tomorrow Day
weekend we started seeing a shift in the
data with the protests you know that
have been happening for the last two and
a half weeks we also have seen a shift
in the data and the data has shifted on
basically every single match
with the exception of deaths we've seen
an uptick in new cases we've seen an
uptick in new influenza-like reporting
we've seen an uptick significant
increase in percent positive which is a
percentage of people that are positive
whose teen and uptick on
hospitalizations ventilate the
ventilators and ICU beds thankfully
nothing that risks our total capacity
which is still at about 50% of the total
but these are all alarming statistics
particularly because they can influence
oh and that's the most important which
is deaths which we have not seen so far
taken but we know that there's a lag
between four to five weeks from new
cases to one unfortunately the evolution
of this disease can result in death so
we're very carefully monitoring them
absolutely and you mention hospitals ICU
beds in Homestead are completely full
now and he said rising across the state
what will you do to ensure that
hospitals aren't experiencing too much
of a surge we have excess capacity
through surgical centers through
affordable hospitals that we have our
disposal you know we do have a surgeon
homestead without a doubt but
system-wide countywide we still have
significant capacity and so I'm sure we
can shift resources from hospital
hospital if need be but the truth of the
matter is if that is the critical as a
critical firewall figure if our
hospitals become overburdened that's
when you see the death rates across the
world and across the country other main
two levels that are unacceptable
absolutely the phrase critical figure
what critical figures are you looking at
when thinking through whether you know
bars need to close again weather beaches
should maybe not be opened as much as
they are right now well we decided not
to open bars you know we have some
restaurants up light bars but I don't
have to police that and crack down on
that and we have but but but we have
decided not to go into what we call
phase three which is opening up of bars
movie theaters nightclubs and large
cause he owns the stadiums
patience of people so that doesn't
usually did two weeks ago we have not
wavered on that and we just implemented
a new rule that you have to wear masks
in public we're doing everything that we
can't not to paralyze businesses which I
had such a hard time getting going but
at the same time we cannot protect our
residents of course and I'm wondering
what systems are in place for as you
mentioned restaurants that might be
acting like bars and potentially not
following CDC guidelines and and
guidelines along social distancing what
are you doing to track that and and
encourage them to act differently we
have a task force that is out there
checking bars and thousands of
inspections and listen we also get a ton
of complaints from residents directly to
me we get complaints through social
media and we investigate those
complaints and we already shut down five
businesses just last weekend alone we're
gonna continue to do that if we have to
and you mentioned the mask mandate as
well which is new in the area what are
you doing to enforce that and to make
sure that all residents have access to
masks the first thing is you know we
understand that whenever you get
something that's so broad right like
massive public for everyone or like
stay-at-home worst it's gonna be
impossible to enforce and we didn't go
house to house and make sure people were
home you know we implement these rules
because most people are law by they want
to follow the rules and we want to make
sure that we have a clear set of rules
based on what we think is best for our
residents to protect themselves now
there are going to be some that don't
follow those rules and for that we have
the ability to ticket them and we have
the ability to in theory arrest them if
there were systemic violators although
we're hoping that it doesn't come to
that off for obvious reasons we're going
to do is educate people to put a comply
not so that we want to penalize them or
shame them in any way what we want to do
is make sure that they're taking care of
themselves and others absolutely and the
data shows that young people are in
particular cross the state are getting
the virus and drugs right now I'm
wondering if that changes your thinking
in terms of any guidelines you might
want to put forth specifically related
to activities young people may be
wait to do yeah we're monitoring that
because the concern is that even though
it is young people that are
predominately getting sick and even
though they are oftentimes asymptomatic
or may not meet as much critical
hospital care they may in many cases
with their parents with their
grandparents and that is the volatile
population are worried but could
contract the virus which has a much much
higher mortality rate than through maybe
it's a four or five X and in numbers
that I've seen in statistics that I've
seen so we have to do everything that we
can to make sure that those in that
community understand how serious this is
and how it can affect them and put their
family members absolutely and in are
there any any specifics about you know
especially in the state of Florida where
we do have a lot of at-risk populations
I'm here in Tampa with some elder
relatives as well what can be done to
keep those relatives who are at risk a
little safer well we recommend that they
stay home we recommend if they can't
that they stay home that you know what
we have seen in terms of our statistics
is that the stay at home or order was
the most effective way of you know
curbing you know stopping the spike and
flattening the curve as they say and
actually reversing the trajectory of the
the increase so staying at home is
obviously the most effective way but if
you can't do that and obviously follow
all the rules you know social distance
wash your hands try to avoid touching
your face of course wear a mask wherever
possible and I want to remind our
audience watching as well to please
comment with any questions you have for
the mayor and I will ask as many of
those as I can I'm wondering if you can
talk a little bit about pro sports
across the state do you envision any
sporting happening in the fall and if so
what will be done to keep viewers safe
well it looks like basketball is about
ready to resume in Orlando although
there's been some discussions based on
the spike as to whether or not they're
gonna start with particular they're
going to start in a self-contained
campus where the basketball players will
be playing without fans it appears that
baseball may have reached an agreement
to start as well and I presume that that
will be without fans
what'll be interesting to see is whether
football begins as scheduled in August
and whether there are any fans I don't
think that it might be the accountant
there are right now it's it's gonna be
allowed for the football team South fans
I know that the county mayor's indicated
that he would like to see a plan you
know from the team if they desire to
have some percentage of fans in the
stadium but I think with the recent
spike
my guess is over the last two weeks is
that you know that was that's that's
taught that was that was uh you know
those were things that were said that
couple of weeks ago I can't imagine that
that would still hope to not absolutely
and you mentioned the success of the
initial stay at home order what will it
take to have officials like yourself
reconsider another stay at home order in
the state and is that something you're
already thinking about it's something
that we can't take off the table but
it's something that we should have only
using that last resort and the reason
why is because our economy's not where
it was when we implemented stay at home
order you know we have full employment
at the time now we have historic levels
of unemployment those who are employed
are making a fraction of what they were
making and so it's a more dramatic time
to implement something that dramatic
drastic and so you know I think it's a
measure of last resort I think it would
it would only happen if it became
apparent that our possible system was
under siege and that our death rate
could continue to climb to continue
unacceptable rates that would be a time
when we would consider doing something
like that again sure and I understand
you mentioning the economic situation
that we're all in but what would you say
to citizens who think that we were
previously in a less dramatic situation
when you already had the stay-at-home
order in place because rates and lower
what would you say to them I'd say
you're right I'd say they're accurate
you know when we implement the
stay-at-home order on March 24th the
high-water mark for mutations 533 in
miami-dade County and 1300 approximately
in the state of Florida we just hit
5,400 in the state of Florida which is
four times greater than the high-water
mark and we
slightly over 900 in miami-dade county
which is almost twice the high-water
mark so you know it's completely
understandable that people would say you
know why aren't to implementing if they
all in order now when you're double the
number of new cases then you worry about
anything there was a lot less known
about a Cobra at the time and so I think
you know they were done as a
prophylactic measure and obviously with
the objective of you know completely
shutting down the virus and I think
unfortunately now we're in a position
where we've seen when we don't act of
conformity with with the rules how
quickly the virus spreads which is
something that I said we started over
and so your message would be it sounds
like more focus on following the rules
in place before you issue that stay at
home order again yeah my message is
that's that's where the massive public
let's see if that will help you know
again flatten the curve once again let's
understand that we cannot be in large
congregations of people which we're
seeing in some of our restaurants and
that will shut down those restaurants
and you know and and and and even when
you're in the beaches you know you have
to avoid being in large large
congregations of people or close
proximity with people and speaking of
beaches something all Floridians hold
dear to their hearts what would you do
would you consider closing some beaches
in order to keep restaurants and places
that are spurring the economy open yeah
the mayor of Miami Beach is the one that
would make that call in conjunction with
command economy
I actually supported him when he decided
not to open up the beaches when the rest
of the state of Florida opened he
actually waited until early June a past
Memorial Day and I have that was a wise
decision having said that and that may
be part of the reason why our spike is
half as intense as the rest of the state
of Florida but uh you know it's it's a
call that he has to make I would support
him if he decided at some point that he
won't close the beaches again but that's
gonna be a tough call as well absolutely
and in Johnson Amir
in the area I wonder if you know this is
obviously an unprecedented time are you
considering kind of going above and
beyond the powers that you may have
utilized in the past as mayor to enact
any more drastic changes to keep your
residents safe you know it's funny
because I get a lot of blowback from the
powers that I already exercise you know
I have you know implemented the mask
ordinance it wasn't like universally
embraced as a great thing I think you
know I think we're even actually being
sued I'm not sure if the city or a
county is being sued for the mass
implementation ordinance so you know
when we when we do things our segment of
our population that thinks that we
retaining their their freedoms and we're
not doing it for that reason and
certainly that's not our objective our
objective is just see some people safe
and do what we think is best for society
as a whole but there are people that
don't like it and that are critical of
the already broad powers that we've
exercised during this crisis and what do
you make of residents rebuffing the the
mass mandate I don't think it's a good
idea I don't think it's good for their
health I don't think it's good for the
health of others and that's why we
implemented it and and they also have to
understand is that we can't ignore the
evidence that we're seeing the die
it's our objective tip number one be
transparency data that is unfavorable
and number two to give recommendations
and create and eights that are keeping
people safe so if they don't follow you
don't hear they're doing is risking
themselves and their family members and
so I you know I I don't understand the
logic and I want to go to a question
from our audience a commenter said what
is the plan with reopening office
buildings and how can we ensure that
companies will keep employees safe I
think this is something on a lot of
people's minds as certain offices reopen
offices are open you know they're open
bathrooms capacity limitations I would
highly recommend that you wear a mask
inside because if somebody comes to the
office infected I could easily be in you
know an area where it can be spread so
you know wearing a mask
indoor something that's a requirement in
the city and
so you know that's that's but a lot of
people are also working virtually more
than ever and that's an interesting
dynamic that has been as a result of
Kovac and has really forced company sir
rethink how they do business and as in
terms of rising numbers of people
gathering in one place Miami is going to
host the presidential debate between
Biden and Trump how is that gonna work
and how are you going to keep attendee
is safe if you if you plan on allowing
people to attend first of all it's in
mid-october so that's a you know that's
still good you know four months away
approximately and so you know we don't
know exactly what we're gonna be the
next four months right now we're not in
phase three so you could not have an
event like that with people in the
audience so right now and look at I know
the press I've gotten accustomed to on
TV has gotten accustomed to doing things
on hits less and remotely so I you know
it's it's it's a it's very possible that
the debate could be had without audience
members if things do not change or if
things get better and there's a
possibility that we could be in phase
three by that and there would be some
other sets of restrictions and alongside
the debate do you envision any rallies
or protests and learns the ones we've
seen now popping out around that time
that could cause concern I'm sure they
will and I'm sure they will and I say
that because I'm sure the protesters
will be there n ain't sure that it will
create concern because it's it's you
know it's impossible not to link right
now some of the elevated numbers in my
hand to the fact that thousands of
people and our streets congregated
closely together for two consecutive
weeks three consecutive weekends so
that's certainly going to be a concern
you can see in the infographic there's
play some people worried enough that a
lot of people not worried enough so
that's definitely a concern absolutely
and I think um some constituents would
maybe push back on that and say that
folks are also not wearing masks at the
beach right so I wonder what what your
thoughts might be on instituting further
guidelines for for beaches and pools and
or
that's a legitimate certainly a
legitimate response and criticism and I
you know again I'm willing to work with
the mayor of the beach to support his
desire to do that if that's something
that is lost to do and another common
occurrence in the state of Florida is
hurricanes I grew up experiencing many
of them were already in a pandemic
what's going to happen to Floridians if
they also experience a hurricane at this
time and what's your plan for that well
you know the good news is that we're a
city that's know obviously that prepares
for hurricanes and understands what a
hurricane is and you know we have a lot
of experience eating hurricanes we're
hopeful that this year we get spared
given everything that we've had to deal
with but I wouldn't be surprised given
that the nature of the year that we've
had that we would have a hurricane so
we'll be ready so he is it's preparing
itself as it would any normal here with
the exception that we always have to
have additional protocols for you know
Kovac you know KO bida
issues related to how we prepare and how
we prepare for it for that for that
hurricane absolutely and as we head into
the fall in the winter more folks from
up north may continue to come down to
the state of Florida how are you
planning to handle travelers to the city
we have the state of Florida has a
requirement that if you come from the
state of north you have to quarantine
for 14 days that so far hasn't change as
far as I know from any other states but
certainly it is this you know makes
things a little bit more challenging
when you're not only trying to keep the
residents who are here safe but you're
not the keep residents that come from
outside maybe even areas that have
higher incidence of code into our
community and I want to remind our
audience watching that we are joined by
it Miami man Francis Suarez talking
about the rise in cover 19 cases across
the state of Florida if you have any
questions for the mayor you can comment
them and I will ask as many as I can I'm
wondering how you are handling social
distancing and what that experience
has been like for you it's been very
difficult I can tell you as mayor first
of all I haven't had Kovac you know you
come out 18 days later and you're in a
different world and so it's a it's it's
so taking me I'm adjusting to it you
know the other day I was at a restaurant
where I was able to you know have you
know not ask how much somebody came into
picture in a picture went viral so I
wasn't wearing a mask
so you know it's it's an adjustment for
me as well you know part of it is
adjustment because I hike oh but the
other part is an adjustment because I'm
the mayor and people wanna get close to
me the third part is out I'm supposed to
be an example and so if I'm asking
people to wear masks you know I have to
you know you know I obviously have to
act the way that I that I ask people to
act as well so it's an adjustment for me
that's something that you know I have to
continually remind myself of you know we
live in a world we're constantly on the
go sometimes you you get up in the
morning and you're going out the door
you really take you gotta get your mask
on so it's something that that's a you
know I'm a human being I'm not perfect
and I'm not ask you my residents to be
perfect either to be frankly what I want
my residence to do is just take care of
themselves and you know to do the very
best that they can and what about
residents who are looking to their
officials and feeling like they've
failed them at you know the federal and
the local level because these cases have
gone so much higher particularly in
Florida what do you say to them well
look I say you know we're doing the best
that we can given about the things that
were trying to balance we're trying to
balance the fact that you know when we
started this economy was in shambles or
was doing great and then you know
quickly quickly went into shambles you
know we we were one of the states and
the cities that had handled it very well
in comparison with other cities in the
u.s. but I think now what we're seeing
is we've opened up is we're seeing the
kind of behavior that needs to await
quick increase and we have to stop that
immediately absolutely and another
audience question we have is it a
challenge that every state seems to have
a different reopening strategy
and some are more strict than others and
I'm wondering you can talk about that
even at a more hyper local level look I
think I think it's really hard to have a
one size fits all strategy not give you
an example just from miami-dade County
that you're saying my median County has
34 different municipalities the city of
Miami is the largest one is extremely
dense you know it's a metropolitan city
you can't you can't true that the same
as a city that is a very small city in a
suburb city your book entry plan the
same as as Ocala for example so you know
they're just you're just totally
different circumstances and they need to
be dealt with in a very different way
which is why we as a city where the last
us tooi to open in the entire state of
Florida because we just felt like we
were not ready absolutely and we have
another audience question from Twitter
user asks will school schedules change
will they be dispersed at all to allow
for parents who are having to work from
home to safely drop their kids off at
school what thoughts do you have on on
school changing back in the fall you
know I haven't had a chance to
participate in it yet I know he's about
to unveil his fall plan soon and so I
would tell your members to look out for
that should be coming out of close and
come out today but if not it should be
coming out sometime this week now I'm
going to be reaching out Timmons what I
get a briefing to see what's going on
but it's easy incredibly challenging
times right now and it's such a you know
it's harder to put it out there because
the ball is moving so much I mean just
two weeks ago we were still seeing
numbers decline and now all of a sudden
in two weeks we're seeing a rapid
increase absolutely and another thing
that we're seeing right now alongside
code 19 is a groundswell of protest
surrounding the killing of George Floyd
and black lives matter protests popping
up in all 50 states and all are you
responding to protesters and what is
your plan to keep constituents safe and
address issues of police brutality in
your municipality we're first the first
thing we're doing is we're listening
we're letting people protest
understanding that there's a tremendous
amount of disgust over the incident
not just in in Minneapolis but so many
incidents that are happening across the
country we're looking at our internal
policies we've made a lot of really had
our own incidents of officer-involved
shootings I have to fire a police chief
when I was a commissioner to cast the
deciding vote to fire because he
policies that led to the killing of
seven African Americans in one year in
city land I also helped fun fully fund
the civilian investigative panel when I
was a commissioner so that would have
somebody oversight over our Police
Department our current chief has
dismissed more officers and the last
three Chiefs combined which i think is
important to have accountability but I
also think we have to continue to look
at implicit bias training to see if
we're doing enough of that
how do we disciplining and getting rid
of officers who continue to wrap-up use
of force complaints are you support
complaints are actually down you know
the time we have more officers don't
have in our history
so you know and and and also it's
important again what our officers doing
that maybe they should be taught in
terms of you know so many different
calls for service of whether it's mental
health of you know acting of social
workers you know we want our officers or
police officers to handle what they know
how to do and let other professionals
handle cases that they that they may not
be a per can and how are you thinking
about arrests for protesters and
alongside Kovan 19 also I'm wondering if
you could address the Muslim woman who
was asked to remove her hijab or force
rather to remove her hijab when she was
arrested while protesting yeah I think
there's two things woman who was asked
that was a miami-dade County the
corrections department that has
recruited me for a job and I think my
understanding of it and I'm not you know
III I think that you know she should be
respected in terms of you know her
religious identity and how she practices
her faith and I think it's we have to be
very very sensitive very careful to not
infringe on on the way people exercise
their faith and so I think it's
something that you know we need to look
at and see if it's if we can get this
type of information without insulting
someone and fringing on their religious
freedoms that's something that we should
seriously consider absolutely and the
question of keeping protestors safe if
they are arrested yeah and you know we
have very few again we've been very
fortunate to office entire protests are
very few arrests we had a seven arrests
and one incident where there were some
thoughts toward being two-faced I think
we had three arrests on the first Sunday
and fifty arrests of four Saturday I
think most of those arrests on Saturday
were dismissed because they were curfew
violations so we've got a very few
arrests we'll try to avoid
confrontations let the protesters have
you know space and block traffic for
them in fact I've been criticized a time
for quote-unquote being too soft on the
protesters I don't you know I don't
agree with that I think our department
is our magnificent job of being
disciplined I'm not unnecessarily being
provocative and I think because of that
we've gotten some positive national
attention absolutely and thank you so
much for sharing so much time with us
today we do have only a couple minutes
left but I wanted to give you the time
if you have any other messages you want
to get across to our viewers about how
you're handling Coppa 19 and how you're
doing I just you know I thought your
viewers in our residents that we cannot
do this without you have to do this
together this is something that we this
is a fight that we have to join each
other and we have to we're not here
ashamed people we're not here to consult
people were here to do is is to you know
collaborate with our our brothers and
sisters in our community and make sure
that we're doing everything we can to
ensure safe
absolutely well thank you so much mr.
mayor for making time for us today we so
appreciate it and thank you and everyone
watching please follow quick tape by
Bloomberg on all social platforms
Facebook YouTube Twitter Instagram and
thank you again for watching